flow back to my to my organs when did
that even happen and when all of that
hit me all at once i immediately started
crying tears started rolling down my
eyes i realized that i was gone for a
long time in my head i just closed my
eyes up and back up and that's it that's
all that happened but at that moment i
realized that i passed out i was totally
gone i was not in possession of my body
whatsoever and at this moment i looked
up and i said
i know i've been keeping that from you
guys for a long time and it feels really
good to let you know but
i started praying together those are my
last words that i was going to say
that's what i wanted to say for the last
path that i took i thought my life was
over at that moment but that's like a
once in a lifetime story man
that doesn't happen to most people
you need to do food as soon as possible
we would eat anything from anywhere at
this moment and we're looking for all
the restaurants and they're all closed
every single grocery store every place
to buy food every place to buy any form
of grocery was closed except the bars
and we obviously don't drink but there
was a bar that had a pizza kitchen in it
at the same time it was a bad situation
it was called hideaway's pizza hub we
were in la hawaii and we had no other
choice but to go to this pizza hub and
we went there we got pizza we came back
and ate it and after we ate the pizza we
knocked out went straight to sleep the
very very next morning i woke up and i
immediately knew i made the biggest
mistake of my entire life
i had horrible food poisoning my stomach
was turning and twisting by six in the
morning i was throwing up everything
that i've tried that i've ate and every
part of me just felt like it was
deteriorating i was horribly poisoned
and it wasn't normal it wasn't like i
would get over it in six to 12 hours
really quick it's done like this was i
don't understand what kind of bacteria
these guys had in their kitchen how long
they left their cheese out how
disgusting their work environment is but
it was the worst food poisoning i've had
in my entire life if i tried to drink
water if i was literally just drinking
water even a small sip i would throw it
up within five minutes of drinking it
the water and everything that i ate
would sit in my upper abdomen and it
wouldn't go down and i couldn't digest
anything no food no water no
electrolytes no no coconut water no
pedialyte nothing that i drink would go
down and i thought this would blow over
in just a couple of hours it kept on
getting worse
after maybe the seventh or eighth time
that i threw up i knew that there was
there was no going back like i was in
some really really deep so the seventh
time that i threw up i finally went back
to the bedroom and i'm sitting there and
i laid my head back and this must have
been like at four or five p.m now this
is what like
16 hours with no water with no drinks
i'm laying back on the bed and i fall
asleep now this is really scary because
i didn't sleep because i was tired or
because it was a long flight i fell
asleep because i was severely dehydrated
couldn't put any liquids down in the hot
island of hawaii i couldn't drink
anything and i wake up 30 minutes later
after falling asleep and my body is on
fire i was overheating way too fast my
skin was boiling so i ran to the
bathroom and i'm again throwing up i'm
trying to drink some water for some
water on me do anything just to cool off
and after i sit back down i just kind of
give up at this moment because i
couldn't even lift my arms i had no
energy at this time
i started calling for my friend i tried
to tell you come to the bathroom come
come take me out of here yo and i'm
calling him over and over at the
faintest of my voice i couldn't even i
could even scream how dehydrated and
tired i was so he finally hears me and
he comes in he's like yo did you call me
and he sees me on the floor he's good
alex get up bro alex yo come on what the
hell's going on alex get up let's go and
you're trying to lift me up and he's
trying to like hold me and talk to me
and make sure you make sure that i'm
still staying sane and as i'm looking at
him i i was hanging onto his shoulders
and he's a medical student so he knows
the signs when someone is about to
really pass out and i was hanging onto
his shoulders and i'm squeezing as hard
as i possibly could i'm trying to stay
balanced and i'm looking at him and he's
screaming alex stay awake alex yo are
you good alex he was just trying to keep
on talking to me and asking questions
and i'm holding on to his shoulders and
i slowly start to see everything go very
very blurry and before i know it from my
perspective i'm looking at him
everything gets blurry for a couple of
seconds close my eyes and now for some
reason i'm on the floor i'm on the floor
and he's on top of me crying and he's
screaming alex wake up wake up he's
literally doing chest compressions on me
because i was unconscious and i wake up
and i'm like what the hell is going on
he was literally like compressing my
chest really hard but i didn't even feel
that i couldn't feel anything at that
moment and he's crying he's he has tears
coming out coming out of his eyes and
he's alex get up let's go let's go i'm
going to call the ambulance right now
i'm pulling another one right now bro
please man please
and i'm thinking ah like what's going on
why is he screaming at me what's why is
everything happening so fast i had i was
so confused i had no idea what was
happening to me
and as i got up i took a deep breath of
air the same second my eyes opened up i
took a
deep breath of air and i'm looking at
him and he's literally carrying me on
his shoulders taking me towards the
scene to cool me off because i'm at this
point i'm still really really hot i'm
all red my face is overheating and he's
putting me under the sink and putting
cold water all over my face and my hair
and everything and he's calling 9-1-1
they said they'd be there in about 10 to
15 minutes and then after that he calls
and as i'm still putting ice all over my
body and everything cold that i can find
on me i hear him in the back of my head
my i was literally submerged in water
just to cool off here in the back of in
the back of my mind i hear him saying
calling up my person my doctor like my
primary care physician in detroit i hear
him calling his personal phone number
saying hey alex just passed out like
it's really really bad and they're going
back and forth and i hear my friend
saying i lifted alex's legs over his
chest and i started doing chest
compressions on him
and i said
when the when did that happen you lifted
my legs up so that blood can obviously
flow back to my to my organs when did
that even happen and when all of that
hit me all at once i immediately started
crying tears started rolling down my
eyes i realized that i was gone for a
long time in my head i just closed my
eyes up and back up and that's it that's
all that happened but at that moment i
realized that i passed out i was totally
gone i was not in possession of my body
whatsoever and at this moment my arms
i'm trying to get as deep
explain exactly what this felt like as
deep as possible when i was waking up
everything was blurry there was a loud
ringing in my ears and my arms were like
a stinging sleeping pain like if you
sleep on your foot for an example when
it falls asleep there's like a little
sharp pain and you feel like it's kind
of numb both of my arms felt like that
they both felt very very numb and at
this moment they started to feel that
shocking pain as the blood was going
falling back into my arms i'm not sure
what this could have meant maybe the
blood was leaving my extremities to go
to my organs i have no idea i'm not a
doctor but when all this hit me at once
i immediately started crying i looked up
and i said
i know i've been keeping that from you
guys for a long time and it feels really
good to let you know but
i started praying to god those are my
last words that i was going to say
that's what i wanted to say for the last
path that i took i thought my life was
over at that moment but eventually thank
god by the will of god i cooled my body
down i was okay for the moment even
though i couldn't drink anything and i
was still severely
subhanallah
[Music]
but that you were willing to
to leave the world leave the dhonia with
those being the last words out of your
lips
yeah that's all it should be
that is like a breathtaking story
that's like a once in a lifetime story
man
that doesn't happen to most people and
alhamdulillah
allah i'm very very glad that he made
his people tell that story and to you
know get close to allah to have a longer
life and to encourage other people to
get close to allah it's a beautiful
thing man
people don't know how death is
yeah
bro we always say like
everyone knows you know we're gonna die
you know nothing's guaranteed except
death
um at least dunya wise and that's the
only thing like allah makes a promise
that you know every sociality is death
and we know we know our time is gonna
come we don't know when it's gonna be
and we all think you know it's going to
be this perfect time where you know
we're going to be of natural age you
know very old we're going to be in a
comfortable bed we're going to have the
shahada just ready you know
and everyone thinks it's going to be
like that subhanallah but it's not
yeah you know that's the reality no one
knows when they're going to die when
their time is going to come bro yeah
male 1 grant is good that's
what i mean bro and may allah grant us
the
the humility like brother lucid had to
come to the truth before it's too late
alhamdulillah he didn't it's not like
you know at that point he accepted islam
no clearly he's been muslim and
and it just goes to show that he didn't
wait till the the last final possible
time to say the shahadah and to become
muslim now this is not like some
fear-mongering or scared tactic to
anyone watching that's considering
becoming muslim um but if you're already
on that boat just just take the step
don't worry about how am i going to be
the better muslim how am i going to give
up all these things that i'm doing that
are haram or impermissible or allah
doesn't like these things don't worry
about that just take the step and become
a muslim have that belief
take that step let go of your ego and
then worry about the rest after
100 percent
um you know a muslim
that dies a muslim
eventually as long as they have iman of
their heart eventually inshallah will go
to jannah
eventually they will even if they're
punished first but someone who dies a
catholic someone who dies a disbeliever
after getting the message and either
rejecting it or you know not accepting
it
they can't they can't say the same about
them that they will eventually go to
that's a scary thought man allah so it's
always best to have a foot in the door
you know actually my childhood friend he
messaged me
uh yesterday
or wednesday before class and he told me
that you know one of his his high school
friends he's really interested in islam
but he's been putting off the shahada
for a while
and
after class literally after class
he or an hour before class he told me
that and after hour class he told me
that his the brother is now going to
take shahada in sha allah they planned
it for the next day at the masjid no
inshallah
that's beautiful man allah it's
beautiful bro these stories and and
so why not lose it bro if you made it
this far
what are you doing bro come on get on
the podcast um let's get an episode in
inshallah it'll be very beneficial we
want to dive deeper into your story and
for anyone that made it this far anyone
that wants us to get lucid on the
podcast
go over to lucy's channel find this
video it's called i almost died and just
literally just comment that comment on
that video just comment you know get
over on the three muslim channel or link
this video and inshallah we're gonna get
brother lucid on
with that being said on me any closing
remarks
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel in sha allah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]